للمزيد حول ابرز ما جاء في كلمه اذا وزير
الخارجيه روسيه تنضم الينا من موسكو
مراسلات الجزيره سلام خضر نقاط عده
اقتصاديه وفي مجال التكنولوجيا والعلاقات
فيما يتعلق بالدول الحليفه لروسيا تفاصيل
عده نريد ان تجمل لنا ابرز ما جاء في كلمه
لافروف
[تصفيق]
اليوم هو ما يمكن وصفه بان روسيا تعيد رسم
خريطه
اربع نقاط اساسيه اولا تحدث عن ان بلاده
مع شركائها تعمل على اقامه
متعدد نظام عالميا متعدد الاقصى وهذا ما
تكرره روسيا في الاونه الاخيره على اكثر
من مستوى ثانيا تحدث عن شركات المهمه
بالنسبه لبلاده غالبيتها من الدول الشرقيه
ذكر بالتحديد الصين الهند تركيا وايران
وفي مع وايضا طبعا افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه وهو اكد بان بلاده مع هؤلاء
الشركاء يعملون على تقويه
التواصل بينهما خاصه في مجالات النقل
والتصدير سواء لمنتجات الطاقه حتى
المنتجات الغذائيه تحدث بنقطه همم مهمه
بالنسبه لروسيا وهي حمايه همم الامن
التكنولوجيا في هذه النقطه بالتحديد نشير
مياده الى ان وزير الخارجيه الهندي كان في
زياره لموسكو قبل بضعه ايام وكانت هذه
واحده من النقاط التي تناولها البحث بين
لافريف ونطيره الهندي اخيرا تحدث ايضا عن
ضروره تعزيز الانظمه المصرفيه بينما بين
روسيا ومن تقول روسيا انهم شركاءها
استراتيجيين مجددا الهند الصين ايران
وتركيا ونشير في هذا المجال الى ان روسيا
بدات بالفعل في تعاملاتها التجاريه خاصه
في موضوع الطاقه والنفط باستخدام العملات
المحليه اشكرك من موسكو مراسلات الجزيره
سلام خضر